is worried about her lack of treatment
for breast cancer
the Cancer Care stopped when ethnic
violence started in May between the
Mayte and cookie communities and she was
forced to move the nearby hospital is
short-stuffed and only equipped for
basic health emergencies
so he
my wife's unwell she has cancer on her
left breast and was supposed to get
surgery done in shija hospital in imphal
she did two chemo sessions in an infall
but then the conflict broke out on the
day we had to do the third session we
can no longer contact the doctor
four months of conflict in Manipur have
led to an informal population exchange
more Mayte have moved to the valley
where the community dominates while the
cookie minority in the valley fled to
the hills victims of violence from the
cookie tribe can't travel for treatment
in imphal the state capital which is
dominated by the mete that's where most
public hospitals are located we are
having like a shortage of drugs issue
because like due to low road blockage we
cannot get the medicine as we used to
get in the previous month I would like
to request the government to provide us
medicine through airlifting medicine to
airlifting and if possible if you can if
they can provide us more doctor from the
mainland India because we cannot expect
doctor from the valley reason
the conflict began after the mete
demanded tribal status similar to the
cookie that gives them preferential
status to land jobs and education
at least 160 people have been killed and
tens of thousands from both communities
forced from their homes since May
the Indian government has sent over 50
000 troops but so far there are no clear
signs it has managed to end the violence
Muhammad one Al jazeer
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera